welcome to this video playing your shake
GM from the US a plate him numerous
times before mostly with black I believe
and so it seemed the same ish variation
mmm yeah play both Bishop e3 and d5 and
but I have forgotten most of this let's
see I think you should be too yeah a six
a form h5 for this kind of line is
normal yeah night 2h months always hit
bit a bit funky but then you need them
to regroup it okay so hmm what about f4
and then taking I'm not sure I want to
play a for real name I can play this
first push-up age six and some basically
always an accomplishment b6 is not clear
to me what this is doing okay um Bishop
age six maybe you can take and play a
form could be a could be a bit a bit
annoying okay let's make sure this
doesn't happen and now Bishop age six
young get rid of this important
important piece the bishop on g7 is is a
strong piece and it also gives a
protection to the king and yeah this is
interesting
trying to exchange Queens
hmm hard to say if with a queen trade in
general I don't want to trade queens
because I've got the better King okay i
don't i don't really think I'm I should
trade Queens my king is just the batter
more secure King h1 rock g one g three
it's them the normal way to to open up
the position question is what about this
a foursquare I could play Knight to f5 I
want ok but let some focus on root g 1
and g 3 this seems like a decent
continuation now you can play F form it
has some positive sides but it also
gives up a form 94 with a big temple
gain and it's an excellent square on
your fault I don't really think he
should move the f porn so I'm just going
for this idea with g3 ok
now night h3 some bit more interesting
than before you can already play a form
mmm yeah but g3 is not not at all
helpful here okay let's regroup it to a
form at least control their form I don't
really am see a better role for this
piece at the moment I wonder if I can
maybe get to be 6 like b3 Bishop b5
trying to exchange ok so we moves it
away voluntarily
okay maybe get the bishop to see two I
could have played Bishop b5 as well I'm
not sure that this is great but it was
an idea wow this I didn't even consider
i mean not at all but is it what is it
actually doing okay the Queen should
have some annoyance value on age 6
I think it's relatively safe the back
rank I don't see a tactic my dears not
g5
hmm given the chance I could also think
about f4 f4 you should h5 check yeah
pressurizing age of seven okay I can
take and give this check it doesn't help
we'll go to age five but then he can
move the night hmm check don't have much
time left and the sun is probably not
the best way to play but I I needed to
to move
hmm now while this night can only go to
g4s got this some somewhat weak pawn on
f5 okay my pawn on d5 is also not Jade
this is this is a [ __ ] damn ok then I
wants to get it to have 6k 93 try to
remove
yeah yeah this isn't this isn't really
too great no problems or anything but
it's not I spoiled some of my my
positive points in the position that
much is clear
hmm and as usual the time is going to to
cost me yeah what one should nine
mornings lose this end game but I
managed white rosanna ah this was
terrible from better and came to a worse
and game okay for me I shouldn't
shouldn't lose him check but I just
played it miserably this is um this
should be just a draw me what I wanted
to do something with G for which is not
really necessary i can just stay put and
then nothing will happen but I allowed
him to play before of course which is a
big big mistake after that it gets it
gets close to impossible to defend with
c4 and I wrote here what is very clearly
better but i didn't i didn't really
managed to get something jack chance so
i think i should they should do do well
on this end game with f5 being weak
maybe i'm i'm wrong it's possible now
the key on each one is really bad yeah
so it should be and it should be equal
but around here after this the straight
of g7 i should really have something but
i didn't i didn't manage they are here
so an important point the computer
points out Bishop b5 i played this this
move but this is just better
I only had this idea somewhat later to
exchange the bishops the point is after
this if he if he really would trade now
note those those weaknesses with rookie
six or the night coming in he just has
many holes in the position so he cannot
cannot really do that probably he needs
to defend like that and then this Bishop
fulfills an important role to to control
on the aid there are many many
interesting ideas now hard to say what's
the best one that I could do to see six
of our like a player form the Sun takes
away important squares and then try to
improve slowly black cannot do much if I
control the only open file yeah this is
where I spoiled and I shouldn't play
Bishop b5 I really owe challege to get
into the end kajak and that I really
miss played okay thanks for watching